et pendant ce temps la maladie progresse
à travers l'hexagone avec 1210 nouvelles
contaminations et 21 décès en 24 heures
le bilan officiel a atteint des 148
morts 6633 cas de contamination depuis
le début de l'épidémie selon lagence
santé publique france dans le haut-rhin
l'un des principaux foyers épidémiques
les capacités de réanimation des
hôpitaux sont saturés sait ce qu a
averti ce matin
la préfète du grand est le profil mans
généralisé de la population française
est devenue indispensable
il pourra être levé partiellement ou
totalement dans une quinzaine de jours à
condition que la propagation du coït 19e
été suffisamment enrayée a prévenu ce
matin le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand en attendant les
français vont devoir s'adapter un
nouveau mode de vie et pour en parler on
retrouve en direct dans les rues de
paris notre reporter thomas bonnet
thomas bonjour vous êtes tout près du
quartier de montparnasse
les français doivent donc s'habituer à
ce nouveau rythme de vie ils doivent
rester confinés chez eux
une mesure suivie mesure qui sera
peut-être suivi on verra puisque elle
entre en vigueur c'est mal entre en
vigueur ces mesures dans moins d'une
heure ce sera à midi pour le moment on
est près du parvis de la gare
montparnasse et vous allez voir sur ces
images de lionel girard il ya encore
quelques voyageurs quelques parisiens
qui comptent sans doute quitter la
capitale il ne souhaite pas passer ces
quinze jours au moins de confinement ici
en région parisienne et il participe
malgré eux à la propagation du virus
dans des régions de france qui ne sont
pas encore touchés ou très peu touché
par le virus est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour lesquelles le ministre des
transports a annoncé ce matin la
réduction du nombre de trains il faut
dire que en dépit des mesures de
restrictions de déplacements des trains
sont encore affiché au départ de paris
après l'heure de midi heure où il met où
les gens ne sont plus censés se dépasser
il ya des trains qui sont prévues
jusqu'à 16h alors ces mesures elles ont
été détaillé hier lors de l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron une allocution suivie
par plus de 35 millions de
téléspectateurs ce qui constitue
évidemment un record allocution au cours
de laquelle le président de la
république n'a pas prononcé une seule
fois le mot confinement ce qui a
participé à au manque de clarté regretté
par un certain nombre de personnes c'est
finalement le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner qui a détaillé les
raisons qui pourraient justifier des
déplacements leurs joues les sites on
peut sortir de chez soi pour se déplacer
à son travail pour des achats de
première nécessité pour un rendez vous
médical pour la garde d'enfants ou
encore pour la pratique de l'exercice
physique tout ça à proximité de son
domicile et sans regroupement des
policiers sont déployés sont au nombre
de cent mille policiers et gendarmes
déployés sur l'ensemble du territoire
pour faire respecter ces mesures de
confinement voit d'ores et déjà des
policiers qui sont arrivés ici sur le
parvis de la gare montparnasse
les personne s'exposant les personnes
qui ne respectent pas ces conditions de
de restrictions de déplacements s'expose
à une amende de 38 euros et pour
justifier le fait qu'on a le droit de se
déplacer il faut remplir une attestation
de déplacement dérogatoire il faut la
remplir à la main il a montré aux forces
de l'ordre qui après justifieront ou non
si les personnes ont bel et bien le
droit se déplacer sinon je vous le
rappelle l'amande s'élève à 38 euros
elle pourrait bien dans les prochains
jours passés à 135 euros
thomas bonnin et en direct donc du
parvis de la gare montparnasse bercy
toutes ces précisions